Oh Ryan Serhant is a real estate broker
featured in Bravo's million dollar
listing New York whose team at nest
seekers sold half a billion dollars
worth of homes in 2014 he's with me this
morning of course Susan lines staying
with me as well as my guest host was a
longtime New Yorker has her condo here
in New York City
Yeah right good okay so there's more
condos coming up so is that a worry here
it depends on who you're asking I think
if you're asking buyers no because the
more inventory there is the more supply
there is the more negotiating power
they're going to have because instead of
looking at one new development they can
look at 15 I mean I think we have 6,500
new condos coming to market south of
96th Street in 2015 we had just about
2,500 new condos come to market south of
96th Street 2014 so that's that's over
double so is that doing something to
prices right now you have you not seen
the impact it not yet people are talking
about it people are thinking about it we
represent a lot of new developments on
our own my team has about 15 right now
throughout New York City and we see a
lot of people taking their time but so
far we're holding steady we just brought
a project to market in the Far East
Village 7th Street between C and D where
typically you wouldn't see that much
activity but in two and a half weeks
we've put 50% of the building into
contract Wow
pretty incredible between C and D with
numbers upwards of $1,600 per square
foot it's incredible that when I moved
to New York that was an area you just
stayed away from and the fact that it's
now a destination for a high-end condo
is just proof of what's happened to the
city in the past 20 years Susan do you
ever want to say I'm just gonna cash out
and go I mean you know you must have
made money on your condo here right I
did it's actually a co-op and and coops
are a little tougher yeah condos but yes
and I live in the Upper Upper East Side
so I'm in Carnegie Hill which is
landmarked
which means that you don't get a lot of
these very high-end
moving in there but I adore my apartment
okay so what is this what what happens
when another bubble bursts though Ryan
okay so you know we saw the financial
crisis and Wall Street burst people are
saying that the tech bubble might blow
up pretty soon what's gonna happen to
prices here then I think you might see a
miniature dip for a moment because of
the ripple effect so everyone will take
a step back and say oh my goodness what
do I do but there's always something
going on in the world whether it's the
ruble or the Euro or the price of oil or
something happening on the homefront New
York City is like this big this big if
you want to be in Soho in New York City
there's only one Soho in New York City
in the entire world and you just bought
and so Howe didn't you I did thank you
for telling me so now we all know where
to invest right because he's got the
inside knowledge no I have a fiance who
has very expensive tastes I can't
believe I just said that no but it's a
there's a lot coming but there's always
buyers looking for New York City
I mean you talk about being in Carnegie
Hill yeah we're also bringing a lot to
the market in the Far Upper East Side
one of our developers Michael Paul
enterprises they do a lot for boutique
condominiums we have one right now on
82nd in East End and it's like keeping
the droves of people away so that we can
show them the apartments in a timely
fashion because I don't want to be over
there and it's a four-unit antique
building where you can get a four
bedroom or 4.7 million dollars with
beautiful roof deck space went around
the corner at twenty East End you can
get a two-bedroom for four and a half
million dollars on the fourth floor hmm
okay so for those viewers though who are
not in New York okay so they might say
this is a little getting a little bit to
my new so what about in others in other
cities around the country though I mean
you know I've heard Miami for instance
it's also you know getting too frothy
levels at some point will we see a
reversal in some of these other cities
that have seen prices skyrocket I like
to look at at history as being a pretty
good indicator of what the future will
bring and history shows that no matter
what market were in it's never just like
this even though people really want it
to be there's always going to be dips
and people buy and sell in every type of
market
so Miami is very very big right now
there's people from all over the world
coming to Miami because there's
beautiful product coming but if there
becomes too much then of course it'll
slow down just like it will in New York
just like it will in Los Angeles
well Miami has the one thing that New
York doesn't which is the nice weather
right I'm always reminded of that every
time I speak to someone there